hello everyone and welcome to a game
that i was very much looking forward to
watching and of course uh later showing
it's uh vastly vancouver versus magnus
carlson it is a match organized between
norway and ukraine and um it's a
four-game rapid match so for um four
players from norway versus four players
from ukraine uh we're going to discuss a
little bit on how the match is going but
this is the first game uh of the day and
it's uh well one that we of course were
looking forward to uh vastly vancouver
versus magnus carlsen and evan chuck is
well one of those players that uh if he
has a good day i always say he can crush
just about anyone and if he's having a
bad day uh he can blunder a rook against
uh
well almost anyone and uh he's been very
active for a very long time uh we've
seen uh some great games where he uh
crushed if you remember the old days of
the linares tournament where he just you
know completely crushed kasparov
completely crushed carp of uh pretty
much any any world champion that he has
ever faced in the i i think 1990
tournament of linares he even played
boris posky uh that game ended in a draw
but he's been uh in the chess world uh
well for forever uh and now in 2021 uh
he is or rather 2022 he is facing magnus
carlsen yet again uh in in a rapid game
you all remember the
2016 world blitz and rapid championship
in qatar doha
where uh vassal defeated magnus not only
in rapid but also in blitz in a world
chess championship uh so he is a deadly
opponent and no one is ever safe against
him so let's see uh how this game went
uh and uh well then we're gonna
we're gonna take it from there so vassal
has the white pieces and he opens with
d4 magnus goes to d5 we have c for e6 at
knight to c3 and the magnus goes for the
very sharp taraj defense
knight to f3 and now c captures on d4 we
have knight characters in the knight to
f6 um
[Music]
transposing to the sort of an english
opening the spielman variation uh c
captures on the e5 we have knight
characters on d5 and now bishop to d2
guarding the knight here bishop to e7 by
magnus the bishop can also be developed
the c5 it's a it's a matter of
preference what kind of a game you want
to play e4 chasing away carlson's knight
from d5 and magnus trades on uh c3 also
knight to b4 is very popular but here we
have a capture on c3 bishop captures and
here at magnus castle so i did mention
these were rapid games but the time
format is actually 10 minutes uh per
player plus 10 seconds increment per
move and bishop to d3 uh vassell has a
beautiful bishop pair and if this pawn
can
somehow disappear uh could get very very
interesting you'll remember evanchuk's
famous bishop pair against gary kasparov
if not if you still haven't seen that
game do check it out i will put a link
to it in the description below uh just a
masterpiece
and the position is a known one it's
been reached in 1962 between taimanov
and natsukanian that ended in a draw
where knight to d7 was played but here
magnus plays queen to b6 and it is now
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game so russell castles and rook to
d8 now nicely putting the rook on the
open d file x-raying the queen on d1
rook to c1 just continuing development
and bishop to d7 we have queen to h5 by
vassal and here magnus has to be very
very careful because there is uh uh well
a danger is lurking everywhere for
example if you make something like
bishop to c6 it's a it's a silly move to
make but just to show you some ideas uh
knight captures an e6 and the the whole
position just opens up the problem is uh
if if you capture this pawn then we're
gonna play queen to g4 we're gonna
threaten checkmate here and once uh
black prevents this we're gonna capture
on e6 with check and once you move the
king now even bishop to c4 we're
threatening checkmate and there is very
little uh magnus
could you do about this if you move the
bishop for example so the rogue guards
the g8 square uh then it's of course
checkmate with captures captures queen
to f7 with checking has to go to h6
queen check here and now bishop to e2
will be checkmate so uh some ideas like
like these are in the position so of
course magnus brings the bishop back uh
he uh wants the bishop to help out with
the defense rook after d1 and now knight
to c6 continuing development avassil
trades on c6 we have captures bishop
captures and now queen to g4 now vasily
is threatening checkmate on g7 and
magnus defends with bishop to f8 so okay
for the moment the bishop is maybe a
little bit passive but he also still has
the bishop pair
and can be used later on so h4 russell
wants to open up the position with
h4h5h6
rook to d7 adding more defense to the
seventh rank but also preparing rook
eight to d8 to double up on the d file
h5 and now rook eight to d8 putting
pressure on the bishop here so now our
bishop is hanging magnus brings it back
sorry vasa brings it back bishop to c2
and now rook captures on d1 we have rook
captures and h6 now
so okay magnus defended very well uh
rook characters on d8 queen captures and
now a nice a3 with a6 and g3 we have
queen to d6 uh sorry queen to d6 magnus
centralizes his queen and now russell
plays king to f1 i imagine this is sort
of a waiting move to
see what magnus will do as magnus was up
on time pretty much for the entire game
and magnus plays queen to c5 the queen
is a bit more active here plus also you
can shift it to g5 if needed and also if
white is not careful some queen b5 queen
c4 checks could maybe uh
grab a bishop or two so king to g1 uh
queen to c for now putting more pressure
on the pawn here so now the pawn can't
move otherwise you would blunder the
queen queen to f3 and now
while you could play bishop to b5 and it
seems like a very scary move magnus
decides against this he says all right
your e pawn can't move let's attack it
with f5 and this definitely wins the
pawn however it will somewhat ruin
carlson's pawn structure so here we
bishop to d3
uh attacking carlson's queen queen to a4
and now queen back to e2 and magnus now
of course grabs the pawn bishop captures
on e4 bishop captures and f captures an
e4 so now it's a queen and bishop
against the queen and bishop with magnus
being up upon but it's a double d pawn
and the queen will have to
uh well be very careful not to not lose
any of those pawns so vassal plays queen
to g4 puts pressure on both of them
sorry on both of them magnus defense we
have queen the c4 and now queen to g6 so
how can uh how can magnus make progress
here uh vassal is uh attacking those
pawns uh so the queen has to keep an eye
on them and also if the bishop ever
moves you're just gonna get checkmated
so is there any way for magnus to make
progress he starts with queen to d5 uh
we have queen to e8 and now comes a5
yeah and avasa just plays uh pawn to a4
uh if you try something like bishop
captures that try and get some sort of a
perpetual you have to play king captures
and queen g6 check it looks very scary
but after king h8 there's really no good
way to
continue harassing the black king if
queen f6 bishop g7 and there are no more
checks so
that's not gonna work in case you were
wondering so here we have a4 b6 by
magnus and the now king the h2 uh we
have queen to f5 putting pressure on the
f2 pawn so vassal goes back and now king
to h7 now the bishop can move again
bishop to c5 is the plan uh so bishop to
d4 uh preparing for bishop to c5 and
magnus still plays it he wants to go
into a queen and pawn end game bishop
captures with b captures on c5 and now
pawn to b3 so magnus is still up upon
however he has four pawn islands whereas
vassal has only two pawn islands it's
not gonna be easy to make that one pawn
count uh so queen to g4 and now comes
king the h2 uh here okay you could have
played e3 right away magnus wants e3 to
be even more devastating since the g3
pawn would hang so king h2 we have queen
to f5 now again attacking the pawn and
vassal brings the king back so he's
offering a draw here
magnus declines the draw and he
continues with pawn to e5 we have queen
to a8 now i'm going after the a5 pawn
vassal says all right you don't want to
draw
i'm going to capture the a5 pawn and
create a pass pawn for myself as well so
now finally magnus busts open the
position f captures an e3 and now queen
to b1 with check king f2 uh we have
queen to c to check king to f3 now queen
to d1 with check king f2 and now only
now queen captures on b3 we have queen
captures on a5 and now we have queen to
c2
uh this comes with uh with check so king
to f3 and the now queen to f5 with check
king g2 now comes e4 now you have the f3
square to check the white king if needed
and vassal brings the queen back queen
to e1 and now you are ready to start
pushing your past a pawn queen captures
an h5 and vassal starts pushing the pass
pawn with queen to f7 queen to a1
putting the queen behind the pass pawn
and now queen to f3 check king h2 queen
captures on e3 magnus is now up two
pawns but that a pawn is looking very
scary vassal pushes the pawn to a6 queen
to f2 with chuck king h3 we have queen
to f5 with czech king the h2 and here
magnus played e3 uh and unfortunately
for vassal it was in this position
animal 55 that the vaseline and choke
ran out of time
and that's uh
that's why magnus won the game
uh so it was a a very well thought game
uh
no no player uh pretty much uh got any
advantage whatsoever and it it was uh
very scary at some points but um
they all you know held their their
position properly here if vassal did not
lose in time he could just push the pawn
for example a7 we would see a2 russell
would get a queen into the game and now
let's say queen f2 check queen the g2
blocking and now magnus would also bring
a queen into the game uh but even though
magnus is up two pawns for example just
captures we're gonna capture here queen
to c to check we're gonna capture the
pawn on c5 uh this is now uh definitely
a draw uh but yeah after e3 vassal uh
lost some time and there you have it uh
but even though vassal lost on time uh
ukraine still won the match the first
game uh match against norway uh with a
result of two and a half to one and a
half and interestingly uh the second
match was also won by ukraine uh with a
result of three to one only magnus won
his game as you can see here against
mosaic
and uh everyone else won their games uh
eventually defeated tari shivchenko
defeated christianensen and kuzubov
defeated a hog uh and like i said the
moisenko lost his game to magnus so now
the game we are going to show next is
actually from round three uh where
magnus faces kuzubov and that game is
just brutal brutal brutal so uh stay
tuned for that you guys will enjoy it i
hope you enjoyed this one uh too bad for
for us that he uh ran out of time but uh
other than that as you can see even in
2022 he is still a most formidable
opponent to any world champion
uh so yeah i hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank usfdfri nicholas
padal andrew dabrovsky kirsten lemmons
and guy lefleur's course for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh most likely with
the game at carlson kuzubov uh so stay
tuned for that uh thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day